- What up blog?
We're back.
New York City, beautiful day.
Pretty intense 2.5 days to Asia.
I'm back on the playing field.
Wonderful day.
- Wonderful day.
Really productive, super excited
about what's going on there.
(indiscernible)
♫ We're unstoppable
- Hey guys.
This is going to be an incredible video.
I'm so fascinated by hiring
and building businesses,
this is one of the most
interesting exchanges I've ever had
in a conference.
I had this in Singapore.
It was incredible back and forth.
There was an insight that I
that I genuinely believe
will help so many.
Tens of thousands of you have
a better business going forward.
Hope you enjoy this.
Let me know what you think.
- [Audience Member] Every business there's
a supply and the demand side.
- The most interesting thing
that I've heard somebody
say in a long time,
because you're 100% right.
It blows my mind that almost
nobody talks about it.
- [Audience member] Here's my issue.
I don't have any problem
with the demand portion.
- Okay.
- [Audience member] The
minute I go out there,
I open my mouth, I'll get business.
- You don't know how to fill the pipe.
- Yes.
And I don't know how to duplicate myself.
- Because you can't.
I don't know if you've heard.
(audience laughing)
- [Audience member] Yes, I know that.
But I need to,
I really, really need
to automate my business
and duplicate myself so that I can go home
and have a holiday.
- I understand.
There's only two things holding you back.
Your inability to operate,
or your ego.
So we just have to dissect it
with a couple of questions.
What do you sell?
- [Audience member] I'm in consulting.
- Great.
Why haven't you hired
more people to consult?
- [Audience member] I have.
- Good.
- [Audience member] But
they're just not up to it.
They're not up to the level...
- Hold on, hold on.
Up to whose level?
Yours, or the clients'?
- The level that I set
as a basis to benchmark.
- Real quick.
Who's hiring these people?
- [Audience member] Me.
- Let's play this game together.
(audience laughing)
- [Audience member] Alright.
- What's about to happen is
you're about to get exposed
to yourself and then
you'll be able to win.
You're playing a very
fun game of you've got
a big fucking ego.
I mean it.
You've got to wrap your head around this.
You're hiring.
You've created an arbitrary benchmark
that nobody's hitting,
because you've put yourself on a pedestal
at the mercy and the detriment
of building a bigger business
because you want to self-fulfill
that you're so much better.
Play with me.
You can't, think about...
- [Audience member] I'm not
willing to lower my standards.
- So don't.
Don't scale then, be a one-woman shop.
- [Audience member] I
believe I can do more.
I believe we should duplicate this.
I've got the models.
I've got everything there.
I basically completed
everything that I do.
All you need to do is take the template,
follow the SOP,
and let's go out,
hit the market.
- How many employees have
you had at the height?
- [Audience member] 12.
- And how many do you have now?
- [Audience member] Two.
- And was it customers firing them?
- [Audience member] Me.
At one point early this year,
everyone left.
I'm fine with that.
- Why?
- [Audience member] Because
they realized that it was
the wrong place for them to be.
I realized that I can't,
there's no point for me to keep anyone
when they can't do the job.
I'm prepared.
- Have you thought about the possibility
of you being a great
consultant but a terrible boss?
I'm asking, I'm asking.
- [Audience member] I have
the reputation I know.
- Okay.
Thanks for answering.
I'm being serious with you.
The reason I went right
at it: I want you to win.
It's a game of ego.
What people don't understand
is that is the problem.
The reason that I've been
able to scale VaynerMedia,
many think that I have an ego.
I play on confidence,
which is what allows me to scale.
I don't hold everybody
to an arbitrary metric
that has no reality other
than what's playing in my own head.
To me, if you're the one firing,
or they're quitting 'cause
the work environment is exhausting
because you keep pounding the drum
of some fake Mendoza
line of quality needed
that you are the judge and jury of.
It's some interpretation of how you decide
they follow the template.
You're just scratching your own ego
of how great you are at the
detriment of your business.
The reason I have 800
employees and high retention
is I don't hold any of them to my standard
because they don't need to be me
to build an actual business.
You decide if you want
to build a one-woman shop
or an actual business.
(audience clapping)
And can I tell you something?
There's nothing wrong
with a one-woman shop,
the way you scale is you
may charge for content,
you may write a book,
you may start getting paid more to speak.
You know what I mean?
Even when I say it,
you don't need to build a
40-person consulting shop
because maybe you don't like it.
It's not that you're a bad person,
it's that you don't want
to lower your standards.
If you're stuck in that,
then monetize a different way
by expanding more around you
versus trying to build out
the actual business around it,
you know what I mean?
And that's okay.
It doesn't make you a bad person.
As a matter of fact,
you'll probably be
disproportionally more successful
'cause you're being self-aware
and enjoying being the one-person band
and making your money that way.
You don't have to build VaynerMedia.
You don't have to build Bain or McKinsey.
Be you and be your best
self your way and enjoy it.
(audience clapping)
Easily one of the best
videos for so many of you.
The question of the day
is: did this help you?
And more importantly,
what are you gonna do about it?
See ya.
♫ There's a moment
♫ In your bones when
♫ When the fire takes over
♫ Blood is running
♫ Heart is pumping
♫ As the battle gets closer